[Applause]
first it's the fake applause than the
real one who the guy told us to do and
that we really like you I love that but
I know why you're excited it's Donald
Trump's birthday and they had a big they
had a big party cake Ziggy candles and
then they played their favorite game pin
the blame on the Mexicans 73 73 he is
and remarkable after all these years
still a natural blonde 73 and this week
went after Biden on age he said Biden
looks different than he used to you know
implying Biden has had work done
and let me tell you something with 23
candidates in the Democratic race last
thing the Democrats need is a new face
the president did not get good poll
numbers for his birthday is kind of
tanking there I may explain why they're
moving up the war in Iran you've seen
that yet oil tankers were attacked in
the Gulf and Donald Trump said he is
ready to point names and blame fingers
there was there's a grainy video of a
small boat that is doing something near
the neared the tanker and Trump says
this proves it has to be Iran who how
else has that technology a small quote
Trump said do I have to spell it out
because you know I can't do that
[Applause]
there was no way Iran is going to escape
Donald Trump's wrath unless they write a
beautiful letter that's how you do it
right if the Supreme Ayatollah wrote a
letter that said I thought I was supreme
but when I saw you Donald it is a little
murky who attacked to what happened we
first said it was a mine but then the
tankers crew said it was a flying object
so that rules out a Boeing 737
and we've ruled out Saudi Arabia because
it wasn't stabbed to death so we don't
know in other news the president the
United States who for the past two years
has been screaming no collusion every
[ __ ] second he kept like good morning
no collusion good night don't do it went
on George Stephanopoulos this show and
said you know what [ __ ] it
collusion it's like Gwen Stefani saying
you know what I am a hollaback girl
Trump said he accepted help from a
foreign country to get from dirt on his
opponent and he would take it again
and and he wouldn't call the FBI and
Democrats was so shocked they almost
took a stand on impeachment
George Stephanopoulos was pretty shocked
he said I have never witnessed a bigger
stain on the Oval Office and I worked
for Clinton now of course the Republican
reaction was swift and severe I'm joking
of course they can always yeah but I
loved it you know all they cared about
what did the Trump admitted to treason a
bigger criminal
that's all this they were upset that he
broke the first rule of fascist Club he
went outside of Fox News
Laura Laura Ingraham said why did anyone
put Trump in that situation it's an
interview with the president not putting
a baby on a horse you know Trump has
many types of lies today came the the
one I hate the most the ridiculous
insulting walk back lie that he tells
when he says something ridiculous and
the next day the pulling this out of my
ass barely bothering to make sense
[ __ ] you lie he was on Fox and Friends
doing this for almost an hour to get off
the phone they had to pretend there was
someone at the door they don't care
about any of this Trump's attitude about
subpoenas
I don't do subpoenas they got a picture
of the other day walking up to Air Force
One the steps here to subpoenas
stuck to the bottom of his shoe
but but thank you all for putting on a
break
brave face tonight I know you must be
upset because I'm sure you've heard
Sarah Huckabee Sanders who reinvented
the the job of press secretary by not
doing it Sarah says she is stepping down
but of course that's her so who knows
but you know when one door closes
another one opens
Trump actually said she should run for
the governor of Arkansas so maybe it's
that she's also launching a new social
media platform resting [ __ ] face book I
don't know and she's taken a position on
the board at the Burger King because
because who has more experience with
whoppers Oh Yahweh
you